[Music]
this represents a lot of money coming
onto the boat and you're probably going
to be out on the town for
a few nights when you get home hey gq
i'm jeremy wade today i'm going to be
reviewing fishing scenes this is the
breakdown
[Music]
first up a river runs through it
so what you do before you even start
fishing you will actually look at the
water and you will try and work out you
know what's my best bet and often what
tells you uh what to do is if you look
around if you see insects flying
these might be insects that have hatched
from larvae in the water so it tells you
that there's going to be maybe floating
insects or insects hatching on the
surface
[Music]
what he's using there is a floating fly
something that some people might be
wondering watching this is how do you
get a tiny little fly that weighs next
to nothing how do you present that
uh on top of a fish and the fact is
that weight in itself isn't enough to to
to get the fly out there so what you're
using is um is quite thick special line
sort of weighted line now the fly isn't
directly tied to that thick line you
will have a a fine leader or very thin
line it's the weight of the fly line
propels the fine leader with the fly on
the end
the way that you detect the fissures
taken it's not really just waiting for
something to pull the rod you are
watching you are watching for the fish
to come up and take that fly off the
surface and then you're reacting to it
these fish are wild animals they are
very alive to something that is moving
unnaturally so if that fly is not
drifting in the correct way uh you might
have bubbles on the surface for example
if that fly is is sort of out of sync
with everything else on the surface the
trout is going to suspect something and
it won't take it
so what happened there
the fish took and then he
set the hook and when that happens the
first thing the fish wants to do is head
in the opposite direction if you hold
the line
that fine leader is going to break so
what you have to do is you have to let
the fish
you have to let the fish take line but
you what you do is you calibrate the
resistance that you give so what you're
trying to do is enable it to take line
but not quite exert enough force
to
break the fine lead and if you do this
correctly it can be pretty hectic in the
moment but you do it correctly that fish
will eventually
tire out and you can bring it in but if
you try and bring it straight in it's
gone
[Music]
it's quite interesting to to see what
they're wearing the sort of the
waistcoats and the hats and all the rest
of it nowadays uh
fly anglers would be kitted up they'd
probably have a vest with multiple
pockets to hold all their different bits
of gear in nowadays you'd also have
polarizing glasses you know that would
really help you to see the fish that
you're maybe trying to cast to quite
likely in that kind of situation they'd
be wearing chest waders now the thing is
the worst case scenario there is if you
go over
uh the top of your waders water's going
to come in that's going to take you down
it's going to be very hard to get out of
the water
one thing you can do to guard against
that is you have a belt around your
middle and that will slow that process
down
[Music]
that fish is running downstream he is
getting into some deep water there and
in this kind of situation that that is
what you would do if the fish heads
downstream you're not going to get it
back so you've got to try and follow it
you could maybe follow it on the bank
but if you do that on those boulders
they're quite slippery you risk slipping
you risk turning your ankle
if you get in the water though i mean
even shallower than that sometimes a
rocky river that can be pretty tricky it
can be quite dangerous uh the water can
carry you down if you get your foot
stuck between boulders uh a lot of
people have drowned in that kind of
situation however fishermen are
genetically
incapable of letting go of the rod when
something is on the end
[Music]
he's he's doing very well to keep his
hat on i thought it was coming off there
but it seemed to sort of land back again
he doesn't seem to have any kind of
strap the hat is not just vanity the the
hat keeps uh what it does it shades the
the sun out of your eyes and so you can
actually
uh watch the water a lot better with a
wide brimmed hat in trout fishing terms
this is quite a long fight i mean it's a
decent fish from a river like that i'm
thinking now to some of the fights i've
had with fish and the longest one let me
see i've had a couple around the four
hour mark but the longest was four and a
half hours
next up castaway
some anglers might be slightly shocked
to hear this but i have fish with a
spear i've spent quite a lot of time
fishing with indigenous fishermen and i
have used a spear generally speaking
when i've used one it's been more of a
sort of a jab for example in the amazon
sometimes you creep around you see a
fish you jab it and you hang on to the
spear so yeah it's
it doesn't always have to be rod online
and if you're in a survival situation
like this you're going to use any method
you can it should speak a lot to every
angler because
all of fishing is about ingenuity it's
about what you can do with whatever
you've got at hand the thing about
spearing fish for example is i mean in
every situation where you can see the
fish nice and clearly they can see you
so that doesn't mean you've got no
chance of success but it means you have
to go into super stealth mode and one
thing you've got to avoid doing is uh
fish are also sensitive to vibrations so
don't crash around tread very lightly
and one thing that's very important is
try not to break the skyline so look
behind you you don't want to be forming
a big silhouette against the sky so
if you can get into a position where
there might be trees you don't have
trees or stuff in front of you but if
you've got stuff behind you that will
make it harder for the fish to see you
okay eating raw fish is something that
people do sometimes in fancy restaurants
that doesn't look particularly
appetizing there but again this is a
survival situation eating raw fish is
something i have done in a
non-restaurant situation i've eaten
sashimi piranha
in the amazon
with this guy who was brought up
with a tribe and what we did we just cut
a fillet out of the back of this piranha
we put a bit of lime juice on it
a little bit of salt a little bit of
something called uh urukum it's like a
red powder
and that was actually really tasty
you've got to be a little bit careful
eating raw fish
some of them have parasites in them
there's also
some fish particularly around reefs
have a certain the meat has a toxin and
this originates in
single celled algae and the toxin works
its way up the food chain and this can
cause like diarrhea vomiting even heart
problems i was actually on a shoot a few
years ago and we rescued a cast away i
mean it sounds incredible but we we were
in the gulf of carpentaria off northern
australia and we were just puttering
down the coast of this uninhabited
island and this guy just appeared from
nowhere and he'd been there for nearly
three days he'd got lost
and he was almost at the
the limit of the time that is possible
to survive uh without water so um
he was very pleased to see us and he's
still going strong
next up one flew over the cuckoo's nest
this is the bait
little fishes
that's right
now what are we gonna do with these
little fishes
that's
i'm liking this already people are
starting to realize that fishing is
really good for mental health in fact
the health service here in the uk where
i live they are starting to prescribe
fishing to people who are suffering
anxiety depression ptsd military
veterans that's it
right through all right now you got it
anybody who's looking closely at the
gear here they might see little little
swivels on there and i think if you
don't have something in the line while
you're doing that the line might get
twisted up it might it might kink and so
uh the purpose of a swivel is just to
sort of
take those kinks out of the line take
your bottom hook
you got it
you take it
and you
push it all the way through
teaching people to fish is
potentially very satisfying but it's
also uh it can be quite frustrating
because there's a certain amount of
intricacy there's the risk that if
you're moving around on the sea
somebody's going to impale themselves on
a hook
[Music]
the chairs they were using is a little
bit sort of non-standard just these sort
of stackable chairs and i think on a
boat uh if things start to move around a
bit they're going to start sliding
around that's the kind of thing you
might expect people to be sitting on in
some kind of town hall or something i
just go straight straight as an arrow
charlie straight right he's straight
that's right but mack back to singing
two steady match man i'm sure it's not
uh
good nautical practice just to let
anyone drive the boat i was once on an
amazon riverboat at night that was
traveling very fast across a lake and i
everyone else was asleep i wandered up
to the wheelhouse and i'm looking out
onto the water i can't see a thing i'm
so impressed by this guy's eyesight and
when he noticed that i was there he
turned to me and he said can you see
anything out there
i said no i can't he said yeah he said
neither can i next up the perfect storm
[Music]
they're fishing for swordfish and the
technique that's being used here is long
lining so you've got
basically one very long line
which is paid out into the ocean and
it'll probably have floats
at intervals and then at
intervals along that there will be hooks
and baits and then after a period of
time they will bring in the long line
and some of the hooks won't have
anything on them but some of them will
have fish on so how they're bringing
them on board what they're doing they're
gaffing them
which is a long pole with a strong metal
hook on the end
they might even get a couple in there
but that way you're going to make sure
that you get the fish on the deck you
know just another detail there you could
see there was one guy over to the left
and he's just he's just bringing in that
main line and then the guys on the right
they are dealing with the
this sort of branch line with the with
the fish on so yeah this is all
it's all good authentic stuff
yeah lots of smiles they're looking very
happy uh the thing about commercial
fishing is it's it's all like gambling
in a way um you can you can have bad
days you can have very bad days and you
can have good days and
certainly with swordfish
the value of the fish if you catch them
is very high and what tends to happen is
that the
the owner of the boat takes a big cut of
any income but there's a residue that is
divided up amongst the crew
[Music]
yeah so what they're doing there they're
taking the fish down and they're putting
them on ice and before they do that they
are
removing the guts and and this makes
perfect sense because uh if you leave
the guts in then some of what's in there
will sort of migrate to the meat and it
might make the meat spoil and also you
with that cavity there you can then pack
with ice
so when you're fishing uh the weather is
always something that you need to take
into consideration and generally
speaking you should be prepared for bad
weather i have been caught out in storms
before also if it's if the weather gets
that bad you stop fishing particularly
well i use a lot of carbon fiber rods
these days and uh if you're holding a
carbon fiber rod poking up in the air
that is
potentially going to act as a lightning
conductor actually there was one time i
was fishing
it wasn't even during a storm it was
after a storm uh this was in the
afternoon this was in suriname in south
america and the storm had moved on so
myself and the crew we went out into the
middle of the river we disembarked on
this rock island
and we are filming something with a
local fisherman and suddenly just out of
nowhere there's this almighty crack and
a flash of light
and without even thinking about it i
just i just hit the deck and we ran for
our boat
and when we got to our boat this long
wooden canoe there was somebody just
flat out in the bottom of it and that
was our sound recordist and he'd been
hit
he later said he just saw this
ball of fire in front of his face we had
to get on the sat phone get some medical
advice he didn't lose consciousness he
was okay
he was missing a patch of hair from one
of his legs you got to respect the
weather and particularly storms
next up the saint
there you are mr timberlake thanks does
okay
right nice nice little detail there
there they're clipping the line into the
outrigger so so from the end of the rod
the the line doesn't go straight back
into the water it's uh there's like an
arm coming off the side of the boat and
what that does it
just holds it away from the boat for a
while
now we can relax and enjoy the morning
the rest is up to the fish
you make it seem so easy simon my
husband worries and fusses from the
minute he comes on board
this is uh yeah it's a sort of massive
error here the the reel that he's using
is he's got it on the wrong side of the
rod this is what they call a multiplier
reel it normally sits on top of the rod
uh he's got it sort of hanging
underneath
he's also wearing a harness and the
reason you've got this harness you know
that's clipped into the reel so if the
reel is underneath then i don't know
what the harness is doing that can't be
clipped in
correctly the purpose of that harness is
to uh
if you try and play a fish like that
just holding the rod your your arms are
going to give way eventually uh if it's
if it's a big fish so you have a harness
that goes around your shoulders it
attaches to the reel
and that means that your back even your
legs can can take the strain of the fish
he's got it i'm not yet he's just raving
and he thinks it's alive he wants to
kill it what we've got here we've got
real footage of a marlin coming after a
bait
and then there is a definite sense that
they are not in the same place they're
in a studio somewhere the script is
pretty good what the script is saying is
is is spot on basically
marlin will they'll come and investigate
something and often they will maybe
knock it with the with with the bill so
what happened there the the line is
actually in a bit of a clip so it goes
from his rod tip to this clip out the
side of the boat and when the marlin
takes it pulls it out of that
yeah that's actually true as well again
the script is good because the skipper
there is saying you know you take it
fairly easy keep it fairly gentle it all
depends on the boat and very often it is
the it's not so much the person sitting
in the chair with the rod it is it is
the it is the skipper is the crew you
know they are the ones who really
sort of choreograph the uh
the bringing in of the fish if you can
snap it that easily why doesn't he
honey the fish doesn't know it's a 36
thread line he doesn't know anything
except he wants to get away what she
said actually uh a lot of people um
are going to be thinking the same thing
if you're using really heavy gear why
don't you wind the fish straight in but
the fact is a fish that size you're
never going to wind it straight in what
you have to do you have to tire it out
first and the way you tire it out
is if it decides it wants to run you've
got to let it run and then when you feel
it tiring you start to gain some line so
it's a bit of a dance you know it takes
some line you bring it in even if you
had ridiculously strong line like a
cable a metal cable
the risk then would be you just tear the
hook out of its mouth
oh
[Music]
right that's that's actually hilarious
because um suddenly we've got a cutaway
which is taken from over uh the
fisherman's shoulder and suddenly
everything is correct the uh the reel is
the right way round i can't see any
evidence of a harness there but you've
got a massive muscular arm uh with a
very tight watch where it's been
flopping around a bit before and and
some some bare legs so
let's see if he puts his trousers back
on in time for the main shot
[Music]
see what i mean about snapping a 36 red
line
right he's just lost the fish and there
was just a very quick shot there of
something swimming away but it looked as
if it had a hole in the back of its head
so i think that was a shot of a dolphin
not a marlin at all it's a big thing in
the water but um with a pointy bit on
the front but a hole in the back of his
head and finally the old man and the sea
[Music]
what's happening here is authentic this
is him hand lining a marlin and we're
talking serious hardcore there just a
rope the hooks on the end and this is a
seriously big fish this is several
hundred pounds that's there i have
actually hand line fished for marlin
which is a crazy thing to do nobody in
their right mind these days does it i
was using nylon monofilament line which
is even worse than rope thinner and i
hooked a fish that was not as big as
this one it was probably two or three
hundred pounds
had it on for an hour got it to the side
of the boat i'd seen it jump out of the
water but it's down beneath the boat and
after an hour the hook just popped out
so i feel for him i've been in a similar
situation
this is what we waited for
now let us take it
[Music]
when you are bringing that line in
it looked like he moved to put it round
behind his back but the other thing that
you're tempted to do because it's very
hard to grip
the temptation is to take a wrap
to to to wrap that line around your hand
now
in this situation this is potentially
extremely dangerous if you're going to
take that wrap you want to wrap down the
line
and if that happens
if the fish suddenly takes off you just
open your hand and it comes off your
hand and you're safe if you do it the
wrong way if you wrap
if i wrap between my hand and me if that
fish then takes you've got the risk of a
knot
and you are going over the side of the
boat and if you can't free yourself
that's
you know we're talking fatality there
[Music]
i'm hearing a sound there i'm hearing
this
which is the sound that a rope makes
when a fish is running and that rope is
going over the side of the boat
you hear this
sound and what it does it actually eats
into the wood at the side of the boat
and you get a nice groove there
eventually
but what's happening is is that that
sound which is an authentic sound is
coming at the wrong moment you're seeing
him actually you're seeing a stationary
line or he's even bringing line in so
that so it's a good sound effect but
it's being used in the wrong place all
this is authentic i mean these fish are
just incredible they will
throw themselves out of the water even
fish weighing several hundred pounds
what they're trying to do is you know
clearly that yeah they're trying to
there's something in their mouth they're
trying to shake it clear
every time it jumps and then crashes
back in the water what marlin will
eventually do they will they'll go into
another mode they'll then start going
deep and it's just the you know the
weight and the the stamina of the fish
that you're you're up against
[Music]
that was interesting
nice shot cut away to the floor of the
boat now when it comes in
in this kind of situation you're not um
putting it into neat coils you haven't
got time to do that it's basically going
to be all over the floor of the boat
it's going to be a mess
and
that is just not an aesthetic
consideration that is a safety
consideration because if you've got line
all over the bottom of the boat
uh there is a risk then if you get your
foot in a coil
again if that fish takes off your foot
is caught in a coil you're going over
the side of the boat what you should
have in that kind of situation you
should have a knife a knife handy
he will begin to circle
[Music]
let the fight come
he's getting tired and he would be
because this is okay this is a clip
that's a few minutes long in reality
we're talking a process of hours we are
talking exhaustion to the point where
however much you want that fish
part of you is is just wanting it to be
over
if the boy were here he could wet the
coils of the line he thought
yes if the boy were here if the boy were
here
he's saying he hasn't got an assistant
you need an assistant to
tidy up the line in the boat but also
you know get some water on it because
that line is going through your hands
it's going to burn your hands
the fish were circling slowly
and the old man was wet with sweat and
tired deep into his bones
[Music]
so what happens at the end here um
you know what an ending to this story
the sharks came and ate the marlin which
must have been heartbreaking it is a
real threat i mean sharks are
they're predatory they are tuned into
opportunities particularly an easy meal
because you know if if you're a shark
and you and you're just trying to chase
fish in the water they're going to run
away but a fish on the line is actually
quite vulnerable and as that fish gets
tired i've had fish myself that have
been bitten in half by sharks what you
try and do is you try and get that fish
in as quickly as possible use strong
gear get it in quickly so that the shark
doesn't get a chance and even though
this is a big fish here
this is a vulnerable fish
okay that's it hope you learned
something
till next time